two black lawmakers expelled from
Tennessee State Legislature after a
protest following the Nashville mass
shooting have now both been reinstated
state representatives Justin Pearson and
Justin Jones made national headlines for
their stand and Pearson will be sworn
back in later today Mark straussman is
in Memphis where Pearson was reappointed
[Applause]
celebration in Memphis after seven
Shelby County Commissioners voted
unanimously to send Justin Pearson back
to the Tennessee House of
Representatives
they killed democracy
they tried to expel The People's Choice
and the people's vote
and they awaken a sleep enjoy
this comes almost two weeks after the
mostly white Republican majority
expelled Pearson and representative
Justin Jones for violating rules of
decorum power to the people I'm really
grateful to the Shelby County commission
for listening to the power of the people
and sending a strong message back that
anti-democratic behavior of the
Tennessee State Republican party is
unacceptable thank you so much in their
struggle Pearson and Jones have found a
national platform this is a learning
opportunity for all tennesseans and for
the Republican leadership we spoke with
Jones ahead of Wednesday's vote is the
issue being a member of the minority
party or is the issue being a minority
State Rep yeah I mean racism is alive
and wellness has he capital
speaker of the house has been a part of
that and we need action to address that
culture and that toxic work environment
they will take action on the original
issue at hand deadly gun violence like
the Covenant School shooting in
Nashville they took their message to
this historic civil rights site the
Lorraine Motel where Dr Martin Luther
King Jr was assassinated this is the
Democracy that's going to lift up the
victims of gun violence instead of
supporting the NRA and the gun lobbyists
on Tuesday Tennessee's Republican
Governor Bill Lee signed an executive
order strengthening background checks
for gun buyers he's also pushing for a
red flag law designed to take away guns
from dangerous people and the truth is
that we're facing evil itself and we
can't stop evil but we can do something
later today there could be some
interesting if awkward moments in the
Tennessee legislature as those two
Democrats Pearson and Jones will be back
alongside all those Republican lawmakers
who kicked them out a week ago
lad I know you'll be watching mark thank
you very much